hear from a victim in the latest
documentation of sexual abuse in the
Roman Catholic Church a Maryland state
report out this week claims priests and
other church leaders in the Baltimore
archdiocese abused more than 600
children over the past 80 years
investigators say the actual number of
victims is likely to be much higher
Baltimore's Archbishop apologized saying
the accounts of abuse are shocking and
soul-searing Nikki Batiste spoke with
Teresa Lancaster who says she was abused
by a priest named in the report
he took all my clothes off and set me on
his lap I was shaking and he was
laughing did you ever report your
alleged sexual abuse not at that time
because he had a garden he would put up
on his desk and I was scared to death